hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
it's no secret that the world is
currently experiencing a shortage of
semiconductors
you may have heard it on the news seen
an article online
or perhaps you've tried to purchase a
product just to be told
that there's going to be a severe delay
in shipment or
no shipment at all car manufacturers
expect to lose out on 110
billion dollars in potential sales this
year car companies are shutting down
production
due to a lack of vital chips ford ceo
jim farley says that the semiconductor
chip shortage
is perhaps the greatest supply shock has
ever seen
93 percent of respondents in a new
survey of automakers said that they
think the chip shortage will have a
severe impact on the auto industry
the iphone 12 came with month long
delays and samsung is considering
postponing the launch of their latest
galaxy phone
so what is going on here how could the
world run out of such a vital part of
modern society
what happens moving forward contrary to
popular belief
this shortage isn't just caused by the
pandemic
let's take a look you are watching cold
fusion tv
[Music]
the ways we communicate with each other
entertain ourselves
learn cook travel heal
build and work are all powered by
semiconductors
for a time these chips were associated
mostly with computing
but over the past few decades computer
chips have become an essential component
of every electronic item you own
just look around you and think for a
second even items that you might not
expect
like fridges and kettles have become
increasingly more complex
requiring more chips essentially
everything in this world that was made
in the last five to ten years
that uses power also uses
semi-conductors
your car light bulb kids toys bathroom
scales
water filters doorbells even toilets and
sanitizer dispensers
the list grows daily and it's not just
these products
even the stuff that makes our stuff
require semiconductors
every stage of production from designing
to planning and manufacturing
sale and shipping all require chips
by now i think you get the point our
reliance on semiconductors
is clear
according to a survey of manufacturers
done by forrester consulting
we can see that the industrial machinery
and electrical equipment segments are
the hardest hit by the chip shortage
not far behind are the it hardware and
computer sectors
ok so why is there a shortage in the
first place
the world of electronic production is
tough and innovation
is vital to survival although there are
many players in the semiconductor
industry who design
chips there's only a few who manufacture
them intel
both designs and manufactures but
companies like apple
nvidia qualcomm and amd
design their own chips but outsource
their manufacturing
even intel themselves will join them
soon
taiwan semiconductor manufacturing
company or tsmc
is the go-to company for manufacturing
with a massive 54
global market share as well as the high
performance chips required for nvidia
and apple products
they also produce low end chips found in
cars
and even microcontroller units this is
often referred to
as the 200 millimeter wafer class of
chips
overall you might be seeing a problem
here
one company makes over half the chips
for all the other major companies
it's the weakest link in the chain
almost everything
rests on the shoulders of tsmc this was
a supply disaster waiting to happen
when the pandemic hit industries around
the world were disrupted
though different consumers reacted in
different ways
for example sales of personal
electronics rose
as people upgraded their home offices so
companies like apple and nvidia would
make
more sales but automotive manufacturers
saw a drop and subsequently companies
like general motors and volkswagen
cancelled or delayed chip orders because
they saw a long sale slump coming
chip manufacturers then shifted their
focus from the auto industry to other
areas
when sales began to pick up again the
auto industry asked them to ramp back up
but the thing is it takes months to ramp
up silicon production
so why so long well these facilities are
very delicate operations
even a speck of dust can cause massive
problems in the manufacturing process of
a chip
a simple power outage at a chip
manufacturing plant will require weeks
of careful
inspection before everything can be
brought back online
normally chip manufacturing plants are
left to run 24 7
so tsmc and others had to keep their
factories running
so when car manufacturers cancelled or
postponed their orders they thought it
was just going to be as simple as
flicking back on a switch when the
demand returned
but instead they were left out in the
cold as chip manufacturers sought to
accept work from other companies to keep
their factories running
and now it's going to take months to
retool
this has led both general motors and
ford to temporarily idle their factories
in the us
meanwhile over in japan a coincidental
fire at the renesas plant
the number one producer for the japanese
automotive sector caused
another supply shock over there nissan
said that they're going to slash half a
million cars from production because of
this issue
subaru said that it's going to make 48
000 fewer cars
so here's a question why can't car and
product manufacturers
just get their chips from elsewhere if
their usual supplier doesn't have the
capacity
the issue is that there aren't that many
chip manufacturers on earth that can
build complex components
even so it takes six to twelve months to
move a design
say from tsmc to samsung
pc gamers and enthusiasts are struggling
to get parts
but yet another pressure was high
cryptocurrency demand
gobbling up even more gpus here to talk
about it more
is caleb borgstrom he's a subscriber
that owns his own mid-sized pc building
company
here's some of what he's seeing behind
the scenes in the pc industry
um my name is caleb i've got a company
like gaming pcs we sell gaming pcs
online for our ecommerce store
what we're seeing is just consistent
increases almost
every single new order we place every
week the price continues going up and
that's from distributors straight from
manufacturers
so that's that's not a someone trying to
buy and resell and make a profit
we're seeing that much of an increased
price just on the actual msrp of the
item
with cryptocurrencies hitting like
record highs
uh all the miners were avidly searching
to pick up as many graphics cards as
they can because mining became way more
financially feasible than it had been
before in my opinion i don't think that
the price will
directly go back down on these new cards
a lot of the higher priced
older cards on ebay will but these newer
cards we're not going to see
a a strong decrease especially because
of how much more money is in the market
right now
uh that's got to end up going somewhere
because of all the stimulus checks
it has to go somewhere and because these
consumer electronics are in such high
demand
and there's so much extra money in the
uh in the economy floating around
the inflation is starting to show up in
some of the areas that are still in
demand right now they got a
thousand dollar check and they're like
okay well i'm i'm already surviving so
what do i do
uh and so they would go and buy gaming
computers okay so when watching this
video
you think you might have the full
picture but all may not be as it seems
as you'll soon see companies may be
panic buying and hoarding chips
causing a fake surge in demand
[Music]
take a look at this chart it shows the
wait times for different kinds of chips
[Music]
some components are considerably more
bottlenecked than others but clearly the
trend is higher
cheap relatively low level components
have been the hardest to find over the
past six months
with wait times rising two to three
hundred percent in some cases
chris roland analyst at susquehanna
states
quote all major product categories are
up considerably
these were some of the largest increases
since we started tracking data
his firm calls the present situation the
danger zone
that is if the wait time gets any longer
buyers may amplify the crisis by
hoarding
here's an example if you're a computer
manufacturer
and you know that chips will take longer
to arrive you'd want to get as many of
those chips as you can
as early as possible the same thing goes
for car manufacturers
if you can't make a fifty thousand
dollar car because of a five dollar chip
you're going to get a whole bunch of
them whether you need them or not by the
way
that actually happened to general motors
as a whole
hoarding puts even more strain on the
system
the problem for foundries like tsmc is
that it's very difficult to tell real
demand
from hoarded products and this could
cause a massive overcorrection
interestingly we have a case study to
examine this very scenario
back in 2017 and 2018 automakers faced
supply chain strains
car makers pressured chip manufacturers
to increase production capacity
in 2019 the industry realized that
demand wasn't as great as first
thought now there was a huge glass of
chips with no products to put them in
renises one of the top automotive chip
producers in the world
had to halt production and lay off
employees and its president
stepped down and therein lies the risk
for companies like intel
tsmc and samsung which have all
committed to large foundry expansions
if they scale up demand which is
overemphasized by hoarding
it could expose the semiconductor
industry to a nasty correction cycle
if demand just isn't there
also not helping is the ongoing drought
in taiwan
where tsmc is based chip production
requires a lot of water to clean the
wafers that go into many tech devices
taiwan is supposed to be one of the
rainiest places in the world
typhoons are a common occurrence but
something strange happened in 2020
no typhoon ever arrived taiwan was
suddenly thrust into the worst drought
in 56 years
in fact one of the primary water sources
for taiwan's 100 billion dollar
semiconductor industry
is only seven percent full and all-time
low
the government has demanded that tsmc
reduce their water consumption by 15
yet another constraint for the key
supplier for this whole industry
and the world
so in summary what we're seeing is not
just the pandemic
it's the pandemic causing people to work
from home getting extra spending
money in the form of stimulus checks
fires in japan
a drought in taiwan hoarding
cryptocurrency demand
and also more complicated cars that
require more silicon per vehicle
it's a perfect storm that comes together
to bring an industry to its knees
and this isn't even to touch on the
geopolitical situation that taiwan is in
so moving forward analysts predict that
the shortage will continue through the
year
chief financial officer at nvidia
colette cress
told investors in april quote we expect
demand to continue to exceed supply for
much of this year
these ongoing effects have led world
leaders like u.s president joe biden
to question how the supply chain got to
this point in the first place
and can there be anything to ensure that
this doesn't happen again
in february president biden signed an
executive order
to authorize a 100-day review into
semiconductor supply chains
it's probably safe to say that while the
road is long a full recovery will be
achieved
but the way industry leaders have rested
the weight of the global economy
on the shoulders of one manufacturing
plant is something that will come under
scrutiny in the coming months
tsmc is a vital part of the global
supply chain
and hence so is taiwan according to the
bbc
around 90 of the most advanced
microchips are manufactured in taiwan
so it's clear that there needs to be
some kind of backup plan if things go
wrong
though easier said than done so let's
end this episode with a bit of a fun
fact
in the summer of 1997 tamagotchi digital
pets
almost brought down the supply chain
after they became a smash hit among
young people around the world
the huge and sudden demand for these
little pets took up
almost the entire semiconductor capacity
of taiwan which triggered
shortages and delays that spilled into
other sectors so there you go
although today's shortage is on a much
bigger scale it's interesting to note
that this kind of thing
is indeed nothing new i got today's
topic idea from a suggestion in the cold
fusion discord
so if you want to suggest videos or just
go on there to have a chat
links will be in the description we're
trying to improve on the community
constantly
if you like this video and want to see
anything more on technology
science business or history subscribe to
cold fusion
to follow my musical creations i've made
a second channel that's also linked
below
anyway that's it from me my name is
dagogo and i'll see you again soon for
the next episode
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it's me thinking
[Music]
[Music]
you